hey there guys thanks for tuning in so
today i'm going to try something a
little bit different i'm going to be
doing a a focus a highlight spotlight
one of my favorite exercises that being
the bodyweight row and i'm going to talk
to you about why it's something i think
belongs in everybody's arsenal and
everybody's routine but it doesn't
really get the love that it deserves so
basically the bodyweight row is an
exercise that involves lying underneath
something that's raised slightly off the
ground holding onto it with your arms
keeping your heels on the ground torso
rigid and then pulling your upper body
up towards the bar or the um gymnastics
rings or whatever else that you've
chosen to use this is sometimes also
called a inverted push-up the reason
being of course that it is literally
like a push-up but upside down you're
pulling yourself up instead of down but
you're using the same kind of 70 of your
own body weight pulling up just that
upper part of your torso this right away
is one of the things that makes it so
useful it's the perfect counter to the
push-up if you're doing lots and lots of
push-ups then you can also incorporate
lots and lots of body weight rows and
that's going to do wonders for you
that's going to balance out your
physique nicely because you can do a lot
more bodyweight rows than you can do
pull ups or chin ups and this is also
another reason it's so useful because a
lot of people actually can't do a single
pull up or a single chin up this is a
fantastic progression towards that so if
you can't do a pull-up then you can just
do half of a pull-up by performing a
bodyweight row there's also plenty of
variations to make it even easier for
example you can stand up in front of a
wall hold on to something that's
attached to the wall say maybe a rope
that's connected to a door handle and
then lean back and pull yourself towards
it so you're using less resistance and
if you find it too easy conversely you
can raise your legs onto something
higher up and that way make the movement
more difficult this also works perfectly
as a mechanical drop set for the pull up
or chin up so you can perform as many
pull ups or chin ups as you can and as
soon as you can't perform a single rep
more you drop down to the body weight
row and continue oh and you also don't
need much in the way of equipment if
you've just got a big heavy table you
can hang onto the bottom of that and
perform bodyweight rows there a
fantastic way to train your lats and
your biceps if you don't have access to
dumbbells or a chin up bar and again
you'd be surprised how many people ask
me about that you can also use as i've
said gymnastics rings if you want to add
a stability factor i like using my dip
bars which i keep right behind my desk
and i perform in between work you can
also do it with two sticks holding onto
either of them on either side you can
wrap the towel around a pull-up bar
there's so many ways to do this exercise
it's something i really think that
pretty much everyone has access to which
you can't say about most exercises
if you're in the gym then just set the
bar low and the squat rack and you can
use that to hold on to instead and that
also allows you to adjust the height
really nicely oh that's great but it's
not the real reason that i love the
bodyweight row the great thing about
bodywork very first of all is that it is
a horizontal pulling movement and that's
something that we don't get enough of in
the gym in my opinion and especially if
you're training predominantly with
calisthenics you've got lots of vertical
pulling motions but not many horizontal
ones pulling in towards your torso
this is a useful movement that we use in
real life whether it's opening a door or
pulling a rope and a tug of war and so
it's something that's useful to train as
well
at the same time though the real power
of this movement comes from the fact
that it's also a fantastic core strength
and core stability exercise so lots of
people do
tons and tons of plank they'll stay in
plank position for minutes at a time
trying to train their core and this is
useful because it trains your core
endurance which is something missing
from a lot of people the important thing
with your cause it needs to work all
throughout the day to keep you upright
and as that gets tired you start to
introduce the possibility of injury so
it is useful to train in that manner but
the problem with the plank as other
people have pointed out is not only that
it's relatively very easy and you don't
get that much bang for your buck but
also that you're training anti-extension
that in other words you're using the
rectus abdomini the muscle on the front
of your stomach to curl yourself inwards
to prevent your body from bending that
away and the problem with that is not
that it's unimportant but rather that
it's something that we already get an
awful lot of already particularly if you
do lots of push-ups where you're already
in that position so what's the point of
doing loads of push-ups and then doing
plank you're essentially holding the
same position with your torso seeing as
we sit in a hunched position all day
seeing as we do tons of crunches and not
so many back extension exercises we'd
actually need more strength that way we
need anti-flexion if we're gonna avoid
injuries particularly in the lower back
and this is where the magic of the body
weight row comes in because when you're
in this position and your heels are
touching the ground you're preventing
your body from contorting that way the
opposite direction once again this makes
it the perfect counterbalance that you
can use to strengthen the back of your
torso the back of your core your erector
spinae in order to make sure that they
have the strength endurance to keep you
upright throughout the day so don't hurt
yourself when you bend over to pick
something up and because you're doing
rows you're also getting the lat workout
and the biceps workout and the traps so
you're getting loads of bang for your
buck you're just sneaking in a fantastic
core stability exercise in there that
will improve your athleticism and your
resilience to injury of course this
doesn't work as well with the front
lever which you think would be the
perfect harder progression from the
bodyweight row but when you lift your
legs off the ground then suddenly it
once again becomes anti-extension
because now you're fighting gravity
which is pulling your legs back down
towards the ground so even if you can do
front lever it doesn't replace the body
weight row you should still be doing the
bodyweight row and that's not all the
other great thing about the bodyweight
row is it allows you to practice your
scapular attraction that means putting
the shoulder blades backwards like that
and what you don't want to do when
you're in the bottom of the movement is
just let them sag like so i mean it's
not gonna be the end of the world but
this is a fantastic opportunity to train
something that has loads of transfer to
other movements like the front lever
because in the front lever you need to
keep that scapular pull backwards so
that you can keep yourself nice and
rigid and not flop about and fail to
hold the position so this is a great way
to build up the strength you need for
more advanced movements and likewise
this is something that a lot of people
have gotten how to do simply because
they don't move their shoulder blades
all that much and by training this
you'll unlock additional strength and
performance and mobility that you
otherwise might have lost so another
fantastic reason to practice this you
can also just hold yourself in position
like that
for extra credit if you want to make it
even more difficult then you can also
try
using one arm and adding a rotation a
one arm bodyweight row with rotation
pulling yourself up and twisting to
touch the air as you go and the reason
that this is so useful is because this
is a movement pattern once again that we
use a lot in real life whether you're
opening a door like i say whether you're
pulling anything else towards you
whether you're wrestling you don't tend
to just pull with a static torso you
tend to pull and twist at the same time
alternatively you can try doing this
whilst keeping your torso rigid which
makes it a fantastic anti-rotation
movement once again brilliant for core
stability so there's so many aspects
this movement is so easy anyone can do
it but i never see anyone doing it so
there you go try incorporating
bodyweight rows into your routine i hope
you found this video useful and
interesting let me know in the comments
down below if you'd like me to do more
like this where i discuss a particular
movement and if you would i have lots
more options available we've got lots
more on the way all the usual stuff i'm
going to be talking about saitama one
punch man training very soon and the
mind muscle connection so if that sounds
good then subscribe and stick around of
course i've got a book that's available
for pre-order right now called
functional training and beyond which
talks about concepts like this the
functional aspects of training and how
to make your training more functional
than it currently is if you're following
a kind of bro split to a power lifting
routine
this is the stuff that will help to
perform better and avoid injury and be
stronger in your day-to-day life so that
sounds cool then pre-order that
alternatively i also have my own ebook
and training program super functional
training that takes a lot of these
concepts and builds them into a single
program that you can follow that trains
your body and mind your mobility and
your speed your strength and your power
so if all that sounds great then that's
also in the link in the description down
below thanks so much for watching this
one guys and i'll see you next time
thanks a ton for watching
bye for now